absolutely and you know some people on
the chat are
actually saying that they relate because
they too are an introvert that was from
kay
um and also jess saying that she too
felt like an outsider and thanks you for
sharing that
and a lot of people say they know the
feeling of not belonging
everywhere i wonder
your own journey with maths i've heard
you say
that at high school you actually
preferred
english and drama and i wondered did you
choose
maths because it's an underdog
[Laughter]
maths is certainly an underdog i cannot
question that
uh i i think it's one of the most um
polarizing and in some ways alienating
subjects out there i had a colleague
actually recently who told me maths is
the easiest subject to teach
badly which i think accounts for a lot
of people's
bad experience of mathematics i've met
so many people
down the years who you know once they
find out what i do i'm like hi i'm eddie
i'm a mathematics teacher um you know i
think
politely they'll say i was never really
into maths if they're being more honest
they might say
much more colorfully that they really
didn't like your experience
and almost always i find that it is not
the subject itself like numbers or
patterns or things like that that they
dislike it's the way that they learned
it
so i think that the experience
personally through a teacher
of encountering any subject it does make
mathematics a bit of an underdog in that
way
i guess though to just return to your
original question
that love of humanities uh english
history and drama for me that was about
you know these are things that i love to
learn but teaching as a profession as a
career
was less about you know what i wanted to
uh you know develop and grow and the
things that i love it was really about
interactions with students and helping
them to grow and flourish and become
citizens who can meaningfully contribute
to the communities that they live in so
in some ways even though i know this
seems nonsensical to a lot of people
um and they've told me so for me it was
not that crazy or an outlandish
decision to at a fairly late stage
decide to teach a subject that was not
what i originally
planned to go and teach it's because it
was about the students for me and the
relationship
with them and growing them throughout
that time
so i know you are quite a devout person
can i ask you did you see becoming a
maths teacher
i don't know if this is putting too
strong a word to it but did you see it
as a kind of
calling hmm yeah look i mean uh i mean
as you point out i'm a christian
and as a man of faith i think one of the
most profound things
is that we talk about professions um but
i think we also
think about vocations and that's
literally what the word means
the voca you know voice it's what are we
called to
and for me i i definitely did sense you
know and this is part of um
you know a bit of tension in the
relationship i have with my parents
as i went through years 11 and 12. there
was a lot going on in my family at that
time
but particularly um yeah well i mean
that was a time where uh my mum was very
ill so she
developed lung cancer and she passed
away the year after i left school
but she you know throughout year 12
wrestled with me a lot about this
decision that i was you know
consolidating in my mind
to move toward a career as an educator
and it sort of comes back to exactly
what you said before
i thought to myself what way can i
meaningfully
serve the people around me that's why
that's why christians believe there is
work in the world is to serve the people
around us not for self-gratification
and i thought to myself okay there's a
bunch of things that i love doing but a
thing that i know
i'm good at is explaining things and and
mentoring and helping people learn
things i actually thought that was a
really common thing
um i remember being an army cadet at
school and i sort of gravitated towards
the younger cadets who did not know how
to pitch a tent
or how to shine their boots properly and
i'd say look let me show you it's not
that hard
and i loved the sense of growth that i
could see
i found that really joyful to take part
in i thought that was very common
and then i realized i had my friends
help me see
that's not as common as i thought and
that was where that calling first
i guess grew in my mind that this was
something special to me
that would enable me to give back to the
community that i'm a part of
do you think that the experience with
your mums
cancer did that help you develop
resilience it's it's a really tricky
question to answer in some ways
um even though i could straightforwardly
say yes
i look back and i think absolutely the
times when
um i grew the most were in the darkest
times that i walked through
i guess it's tricky to answer because i
don't know what might have happened
otherwise i can kind of guess look into
my reverse crystal ball um i do know as
the youngest child
a [ __ ] ashamed to say this but my mum
kind of babied me a little bit
and looked after me so well and i think
she um
because i had some health issues when i
was a lot younger
um just really cared for me and was so
tender and and loving in so many
different ways and had a lot of
sympathy for the kind of like physical
suffering that i went through as a
little kid
and so i think i had to grow up really
really fast
and especially as my family around me
aged and sort of
moved on to their different things the
resilience that that experience gave to
me
was the only thing that enabled me to
survive and be a
you know critical part of my family you
know moving through
that grief so i guess my short answer to
that is yes
but i do wonder what might have happened
otherwise
eddie i have to say we've actually got
three callers from india which is
super super exciting so hi everybody
eddie um you started putting your
lessons online in 2012. that's
pretty much nearly a decade ago because
of a boy who was sick
and missing his lessons but i wonder
what
kept you going beyond that did you
get encouragement or did you think this
is a great way to share that with
everybody what was the motivation
yeah it's a lovely question i i do think
to myself um with a little bit of
embarrassment
that i would love to claim credit for
having had a very strategic plan for how
i'd worked it all out
and here's my five-year trajectory and
the goals and targets i was aiming for
but in fact you know i was doing this
online and
that student who you mentioned um he
went on to graduate from school
and i thought oh okay well the original
purpose for me putting these videos
online has kind of ceased is there a
point
and it was actually and this happened so
often it was my students
who taught me they really gave me a
lesson at this point they said
mr wu there are so many of our friends
who
are so grateful that they can actually
even though they're not here at this
school
um they could never have the chance to
learn from you face to face
they can actually learn via you know
these
very simple humble videos of i'm not
doing anything special
it was literally just my everyday
classroom lesson and i just hit record
on it
and for me to realize wow there's
actually an impact
that i can have beyond the classroom now
even
just the 30 students in front of me that
to me
is just mind-boggling that i get to have
a role in helping to influence them and
and help them grow and learn
and to know that i can go even further
beyond that i mean that
i'm delighted that there are so many
people from india i happen to know that
a lot of the
there's a significant proportion of the
people who watch my videos from there in
the us and the uk and
pretty much anywhere else that english
is spoken because mathematics is a very
universal language so i think it was
that knowledge
that something i could do that was super
simple
that was not kind of there's nothing
special
about what's happening in my classroom
it's the same thing you would see if you
walked into
100 classrooms around australia around
the world
where dedicated teachers are pouring
themselves out for the sake of their
students
it's not special but opening the door to
that experience through the internet
that's the thing which i thought i can't
close that now i want to keep doing this
well it is special eddie and i'll just
read you out some of the things that are
coming across at the moment i mean
joanne
is saying that she relates to how you
feel about being
an australian asian and being perceived
in australian society
even though there we feel you know there
are a lot of a lot of asians from
all parts at the moment but
she absolutely feels with what you were
saying and
and emma is um in lockdown with her two
boys age
nine and seven watching from sydney so
you're right i mean this this um virtual
world really does
create connections i'm interested
that you have more than 1.24 subscribers
that was last time i looked
at least 60 million views i mean do you
ever
ask yourself where is this going or when
am i gonna stop
yeah i i do pose that question to myself
every now and then i mean i'm a person
who works with numbers every day
and yet i mean i i teach at a very large
school um trebrick technology high
school has 2
000 students but except for when we have
evacuation drills
you literally never see all 2000
students in one place at the same time
because
even our very large uh school hall
doesn't fit everybody in so when we have
an assembly
some people are out doing other things
while the rest of us are in there
um listening to speakers or seeing
awards being presented
2 000 people just staring out at them
it's enough to boggle the mind
and to know then that the numbers go so
far beyond that
um really just i mean it makes me think
about
numbers in astronomy it's like oh this
star is however many millions of
kilometers away and you just kind of
think for a moment you reflect and
realize
you know what i have no idea what the
magnitude of those numbers
is and i guess for me what it comes down
to
is even for the size of those numbers in
for the quantity
it's actually the quality that matters
most to me every now and then
i'll get an email or a message from
someone who said you know
um thank you for making these videos
available it's what helped me get
through you know this challenging
experience of a tough subject or you
know our
whole district was on lockdown and we
didn't have online learning but i could
access your resources
to me the difference i can make in a
single life that's the thing
more than the size of the numbers that
really motivates me and encourages me to
keep going